jugando al gato y al ratón con las
autoridades los manifestantes
prodemocracia volvieron a las calles de
mianmar la represión policial contra los
manifestantes se ha intensificado en los
días recientes y este sábado las fuerzas
de seguridad dispersaron a la multitud
con gases lacrimógenos en dawei mientras
que en rangún la policía disparó balas
de goma y decenas de personas fueron
detenidas una mujer murió durante los
disturbios por la represión policial en
movilla según medios locales lo que
dejaría cuatro manifestantes y un
policía muertos desde que inició el
movimiento de desobediencia civil hace
casi cuatro semanas los manifestantes
cuentan con un nuevo apoyo clave el
viernes el embajador de mianmar ante
naciones unidas les instó a no rendirse
y levantó la mano con el saludo que
representa a los manifestantes
necesitamos la acción más enérgica
posible de la comunidad internacional
para poner fin inmediatamente al golpe
militar para dejar de oprimir a la gente
inocente y devolver el poder al pueblo y
para restaurar la democracia and to go
democracy
los militares dicen que tuvieron que
intervenir por las acusaciones de fraude
electoral en noviembre de 2020 pero la
comisión electoral de entonces dijo que
no había pruebas de ello la nueva
comisión electoral posterior al golpe de
estado anuló el viernes los resultados
de los pasados comicios la líder del
país reconocida internacionalmente y
elegida en las urnas
ansa el sushi fue detenida luego de ser
depuesta y sigue retenida según amnistía
internacional los cargos son inventados
está previsto que comparezca ante el
tribunal el lunes